he's the College GameDay host and
gameday is in Waco this Saturday it's
Oklahoma and number 13 Baylor game day
at 9 a.m. Eastern on ESPN and then they
have a game on ABC at 7:30 Eastern rece
Davis joins us so Reese let's start with
the important question have you ever
been mad the answer to that question Dan
is yes on many occasions most recently
something went wrong on the show I don't
want to say exactly what it was for fear
of embarrassing and value trusted friend
and colleague but I let him know and on
no uncertain terms in the moment that I
was less than pleased yes wouldn't hurt
I yell at him all the time when you
looked at the right you know when you're
doing this show last night and you're
doing it in real time you know with the
reveal what what kind of goes oh boy
all right I'm surprised at that was
there a moment last night where you felt
like okay didn't expect that no not
really because I did expect ls here to
be number one and it was funny I had set
the over-under for Minnesota at number
eight and as the day went on yesterday I
thought you know what that might be too
low and as it turns out they fell right
at 8:00 so I wouldn't say anything
really surprised me other than the fact
just a mild surprise that Oklahoma
slipped again and that both of the
pac-12 teams appear to be in much better
shape than the big ten overall I mean
I'm sorry then the big 12
pardon me the big 12 overall not that
that surprising but the fact that there
hardly seems to be a path for the big 12
champion absent a whole bunch of teams
losing in front of them to end up making
it to the playoffs
I was wondering this that yes Alabama
lost at home they came back and made
that a great game and but you did lose
to the now number one team in the
country should you fall as far as
Alabama did if you think they're that
good to begin with and they did lose to
now the number one team it's not like
they lost to South Carolina they lost to
LSU
I thought Alabama
should be four I still think they're one
of the four best teams I know this all
plays out Reese but I do you follow my
logic that we sometimes give you a whole
lot of credit for a win like that and
maybe not enough credit for a loss like
that I agree with you
but I think here's the problem for
Alabama I think just losing the game
opened up a deeper look into their
resume I think most people agree with
you that at least watched games that
they are probably one of the four best
teams but they aren't as good and they
aren't as a complete a teams they've
been in recent years their defense is
just not by Alabama standards very good
it's you know it's good by average
standards in college football but I mean
they had a very poor defensive
performance on Saturday much of that was
caused because LSU's offense is
excellent that's for sure I think that
the fact that they lost the game opened
up a little deeper look into their
resume and just by bad luck for Alabama
there's not much there you know they're
not conference typically you know
includes the Florida State and SC
Michigan this year's Duke Texas A&M
hasn't been as good as anticipated South
Carolina is one of their crossover games
they've been you know absent or part
from the wind at Georgia they've been a
near disaster so you know they don't
have much on the resume and that's why I
think it's going to be hard for them to
wind up in the and the four unless a
bunch of teams lose and sort of hand it
to them and will you be committed with
no other choice but then put out a max
pac-12 has a little bit of an opening
here with Oregon and Utah but they're
gonna cancel each other out eventually
aren't they they both need each other to
go into that pac-12 championship game
with one loss and Oregon could also use
a boost from Auburn winning a couple of
games you know beating Alabama Georgia
they have both of those left on their
schedule both of the majority hair but I
think the pac-12 has a decent shot at
this day and I really do because the
only way the SEC gets to N is if you
know one loss Georgia beats LSU and get
Georgia and LSU in the field I say the
only way I guess the other
that scenario exists but you know if you
have one lost pac-12 teams playing each
other for the championship and you have
just one team for me I think the pac-12
champion particularly if it's Oregon has
a really good path to the playoffs so
yeah I think there's a terrific champion
and on top of that I think Morgan's
pretty good I think I think they would
be they would be most deserving
I think Utah Utah has been really
efficient on offense and therefore track
is bataillon Huntley's played really
well but defense is where they really
make their hay they've got a tremendous
defensive front with a lot of guys that
are going to be playing in the NFL and
you have people we're talking to reach
Davis from ESPN's College GameDay
you know everybody they be part of this
the ranking show is to get people fired
up and you want people who are angry and
you you want college football to be a
topic right now right I understand that
and that's why I always tell people to
calm down it you can have fun with it
but I if you know like Minnesota we're
gonna have pj fleck on next hour i don't
know if he's angry or disappointed you
know you got a beat Iowa you can't be
worried about where you are right now
and then you got Wisconsin and then if
you get to the big 10 type if you win
you're going into the playoffs because
you will have earned this and that's why
you got to tamp it down this isn't what
you want to hear cuz you want right you
want ratings for this show I'm telling
people just relax it's all gonna play
out with that sort of back to your very
first question of our visit here about
getting mad I say the same thing I think
it's interesting and fun and compelling
and it gives you a reflection of how
those certain people are thinking but
it's not a finished product and they
don't evaluate the things like the
conference championships which I you
know I questioned how how much of a
factor that should be anyway because the
Thompsons aren't the same but they don't
evaluate that until those things are won
and that's at the end and you know on
the subject of Minnesota I haven't
brought up last night I think Minnesota
is in such a good position in my
judgment they could afford a loss to
Iowa but then if they come back and beat
Wisconsin and then when the Big Ten
championship game presumably against
Ohio State they're going you know I mean
so I can't imagine being in
in a better position in terms of
determining your own fate
then Minnesota is right now if you're
not one of those top three other Peter
teams then being number eight and
undefeated and having those types of
games in flooded you is a really good
position for Minnesota
what do you think the committee would
rather see LSU Alabama rematch or LSU
Ohio State jobber o rematch against his
former school I think the committee does
its best to try to avoid thinking about
such things but there is going to be an
absolute okay with family program
crapstorm
if it's LSU Alabama rematch you know
unless unless everybody else has lost
too and it's like well what else you're
going to do and everybody kind of
understands it they I I've got to
believe that they're human they don't
want that and it would be it would be
great theater and I'm not saying that
was don't misunderstand that I don't
think that will influence their
decisions because I think they really
try hard to avoid that type of thing I
have respect for their honor and
integrity of trying to do the right
thing you know they can't penalize a
team because they don't want to see a
rematch but at the same time if you've
got them
if you injected them with truth serum
they probably rather not have that but
the Joe Pearl versus Ohio State which
was not the quarterback rematch we
anticipated the preseason we thought
Justin Fields against Georgia which
could still happen
or you know Jalen against Alabama which
I is unlikely to happen unless it
happens in a Sugar Bowl or something you
know those are the types of things I
think we expected and we may wind up
with Joe Perot against Ohio State which
would just be fascinating theater that's
as close as I think I've heard you swear
you said crap crap storm allowed on your
show I don't know oh yeah yeah yeah it's
totally clear yeah totally cleared by
the u.s. censors best college town for
eating is where whoo that's a best
college town for eating I'm going to say
Baton Rouge I guess good I mean there
are several good options there I'll tell
you an underrated one too that we don't
think it's really college town the
college game
went there a couple of weeks ago Memphis
is really good ooh yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah can't go wrong with that
hey great to talk to you Reese hope
you're well and tell the boys we set a
low and we'll be watching this weekend
all right sounds good dad great talking
to you that's reach Davis for more Dan
Patrick show tune in to audience Channel
239 on DirecTV stream for free on BR
live or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]